you know instead of they're listening to
their husbands we're gonna say Follow
Your Heart Right like why do we have
phrases like that follow your heart what
happens when women follow their heart
it's like we get pregnant by Pookie and
Ray Ray right it's like it's like we'll
marry a criminal when we follow our
heart there's a reason that in history
they have never let women follow our
hearts what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to my whiteboard videos where I
go over trends that I really see in
society so today I want to do a part two
of how men and powerful people have used
women by giving us the right to vote to
ruin everything so the goal of a society
be to make money or have strong family
units that create good children and good
people I would argue number two so if
this is the goal it's a bad heart but
just imagine imagine that's that should
be the goal man woman together right but
what happened was for whatever reason
there's a group of people or I don't
know an institution someone out there
that thought the best option would be
not together a broken family unit now
this sounds horrible right man woman
apart okay so what did they do they
thought to themselves we can convince
women about it so what are we going to
do first we're going to give women the
right to vote and make them think that
we're equal so men and women are equal
now how did they do this number one
propaganda they knew and the early 1900s
that if they tell women basically
anything that we just believe it it's
like if you get in a woman's ear and
just tell her for things for whatever
reason we believe it so in the early
1900s they started getting on the radio
and some themes that I noticed is one
that women can do no wrong women are
just these sweet little angels two
division three equality so men and women
are equal you should be fighting for
equality and men are bad men are evil
that's why you hear these women come on
the show they'll be like oh if I submit
to a man he's gonna he's the worst thing
ever so basically these people said
we're gonna use the women give them the
right to vote even though most women
didn't even want the right to vote and
warned the problems that come with it
because giving the women giving women
the right to vote is feminism why
because it implies that women are equal
that that is the foundation of feminine
men women so what did they do the
feminists essentially infiltrated
institution okay so they go into the
school system and there's a couple
trends that I really see that feminists
they send women to Institute now what
institutions am I talking about hold on
so basically the elites or whoever it is
I don't even know who it is the
feminists will say I want to control an
institution so how can we control an
institution the first thing we're going
to do is put propaganda on the radio get
in these chicks ears um social media
radio TV all the same messaging music
too these are all tools that they use
then we're gonna send women into the
institution so we're going to send women
to college we're going to send women to
sports and in the Arts extracurricular
activities we're going to send women to
work we are just going to send women
okay because we know that if we get in
their ears with propaganda we can
control them now they thought how can we
control them even better if they're not
led by a man and they think that they
have equal say as the man in the
household and that's what's happening
women are making the majority of
consumer decisions in the household
women tend to lead relationship there's
a reason we a phrase is like she wears
the pants why because that implies that
we are what back to equal equal which is
all feminine so first they send the
women to the institutions and what
they'll do is they'll make women think
we're more important than we are yes so
they'll basically make us de-narse and
we go into these institutions and the
men will be talking and we don't like
the way that word sounds so the first
thing we'll do is we'll go in
institutions and change work so for
example the legal ones the women went in
there and we're like
forced sex and the feminists came in and
say No it should be sex without consent
now why is that a bad thing because that
makes it more subjective they went into
the school system and the women came
into the school system and around the
70s to the 80s and really ruined school
because they made it more subjective
instead of objective it used to be you
had a standardized test you studied for
it for it you either failed or you
succeeded now you have papers you have
essays which is all based on feelings
how the women feel and then we change
the grading scale make it easier it's
like so what they'll do is they'll send
the women in the institution change all
these words in the institutions and then
add in our version of HR to police the
men so either bring in the HR board the
HR will bring in the school board
meetings so the elite said let's give
women the right to vote so they think
that they're equal then we're going to
get in their ears and say the men are
the bad women know everything you know
more than men you're equal to men and
anything that they can really push to
cause division then they decide let's
Infiltrate The institutions let's get
into school now I mean how annoying are
the like School Board you you guys
already know School Board the worst
Sports and art so we're gonna replace
the family unit at home we're gonna give
sports teams so the women instead of
being at home supporting the men we're
gonna make these leagues that make no
money so we can just take women to
pursue Sports art career whatever it is
or send them to work right so instead of
having a family supporting the men we're
gonna give them these jobs now remember
at work a lot of these jobs are
subsidized by the government and what
happens when women start making a lot of
money well we start thinking we're
better than the men which alas you know
causes division let's take myself as an
example right I'm doing some work
talking on YouTube but at the end of the
day I'm just talking why would I think
I'm better than a plumber an electrician
a bus driver that makes Society run but
yet we just had national news headlines
of a woman doing something similar to me
talking in a microphone thinking she's
better than a bus drive how crazy is
that when we need those men to run
Society but it goes back to let's break
up the family we're going to give women
these jobs that we don't even need and
make them think that they're better than
the men and on top of that then four
we're going to give them the tools to
ruin everything we're gonna get in
women's ears you know instead of their
listening to their husbands we're going
to say Follow Your Heart Right like why
do we have phrases like that follow your
heart what happens when women follow
their heart it's like we get pregnant by
Pookie and Raven right it's like it's
like we'll marry a criminal when we
follow our heart there's a reason that
in history they have never let women
follow our hearts but we have these we
have these institutions that back this
up so the legal system so they said
follow your heart ladies make a baby
with that man
um sleep sleep with everybody
and then you can legally he make a kid
with a with a bad guy take his money
take his kid and now we have a woman I'm
gonna just put a woman above a man and
then there's the little so now we have
these this is the new family unit The
Woman Led household because because
again we have a legal system that makes
the contract of marriage very unfair
where if the woman leaves she gets
everything and if the man leaves he
loses everything so what happens is the
man is always constantly trying to make
the women happy and are these women ever
happy no I mean what do they say if you
give a woman everything she'll still not
be happy it's like okay on top of that
they gave us these jobs so we could live
without men so they said here go be
pretty here's your only fans go talk
into a microphone go have your HR job
that we don't need we're gonna overpay
you so you again think that you are
better than the men and we break up the
family because then the women are like
oh I can't marry this guy because he
doesn't make enough money even though
his job is more needed than yours and
third off they gave us birth control so
they said sleep with who you want
um abort the kid if you're irresponsible
and and the funny thing is they they
keep trying to put us on the birth
control younger and younger and younger
all of these policies go towards
breaking up the family unit and a female
lead house the legal system goes towards
giving women the upper hand so they lead
the family the subsidized jobs give
women the opportunity to leave the
family and birth control gives women
complete reproductive power so we get to
pick how many kids we have we get to
pick when we get married we get to pick
we get to pick whether the kid is born
or not we get to pick what mate we have
which we all know in the last hundred
years women have had more mate selection
than ever in history and yet we have
chosen to be absolute [__] it's crazy
now we have only fans models we have all
this crazy when it's like feminism said
we could do anything and this is what we
choke
um back to the birth control on top of
that it gave women full reproductive
power to the point the men just feel
powerless so this is really the system
that the I don't know who maybe Elites
maybe feminists whatever it was they
gave us the right to vote then they get
in our ear through propaganda and they
preach women are Queens women are the
best anything to divide the family
you're equal to men which we all know
leads us to failure men are bad and then
they created these institutions to make
us feel more special than we are and
then gave us the tools to ruin men
financially emotionally and basically
ruin society and now we have a below now
what do we have what does this all equal
no kids now we have a lowering
replacement rate and Society May
collapse but don't worry just give women
the right to vote and nothing bad'll
happen that was totally a good idea yeah
women and men are equal or maybe maybe
I'm crazy I don't know let me know in
the comments guys subscribe to the
channel ring that notification Bell and
I'll talk to you next time